wusstest du dass du eierschalen super
einfach im garten wieder verwenden
kannst und weil eier herkommen wo sie
nun mal herkommen ist es ganz wichtig
dass du deine eierschalen erstmal
entweder in kochendem wasser
sterilisiert oder einfach mit in den
backofen packs bevor du sie im garten
verwendet weil er sonst salmonellen
drauf sitzen könnten in allen steckt
außerdem richtig viel kalzium und
deswegen kannst du aus denen einen
richtig tollen kanstinger für deine
pflanzen herstellen dafür ist es aber
ganz wichtig dass du die eierschalen
richtig fallen mörders oder zerbröselt
damit die pflanzen das calcium überhaupt
aufnehmen können dass schaden pulver
kochst du dann in wasser und dass das
ganze abkühlen bevor du deine pflanzen
dann damit gehst du kannst mit
eierschalen auch super gut deine
jungpflanzen vor schnecken schützen
deswegen einfach die eierschalen mal so
toth zerbröseln und dann stehst du die
wie so ein schutzwall einmal großzügig
um deine jungs ländchen drum rum und
wenn du selber hühner hält dann kannst
du für den ultimativen eierschalen
recyclingkreislauf einfach die
eierschalen guter kleinen sie dann
deinen hühnern wieder mit ins futter
mischen